[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا وسهلا بكم الاف المستوطنين
يشاركون بمسيره الاعلام الاسرائيليه بينهم
وزير الامن القومي في القدس بعد اقتحامات
للاقصى بمشاركه وزير واعضاء بالكنيست في
حين اعتدى مستوطنون على فلسطينيين في
القدس وحماس تحمل الاحتلال المسؤوليه عن
الاعتداءات على الاماكن المقدسه والسلطه
الفلسطينيه تحذر من تفجر الاوضاع
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بالاسلحه الثقيله في الخرطوم
تزامنا مع استمرار المحادثات غير المباشره
بين الجانبين في جده ومصادر الطبيه تقول
ان عدد الضحايا منذ بدء المواجهات ارتفع
الى اكثر من
830 قتيلا ونحو
3,500 مصعب
هجوم صاروخي مكثف على اوكرانيا اسقاط معظم
الصواريخ التي استخدمت في الهجوم والسلطات
القرم الموالي لروسيا توقف العمل بخط
للسكك الحديد بعد خروج قطار شحن عن مسارح
وكيف تقول ان الخط المستهدف كان لانداد
القوات الروسيه بالعتاد وموسكو تقول ان
هذه الاعمال لن تمر دون رد
الشرطه الباكستانيه تواصل وتطويقها محيطي
منزل عمران خان في لاهور للمطالبه بتسليم
عشرات المعتصمين من انصار الرئيس الوزراء
السابق لمحاكمتهم في تهم بليهاب وعمران
خان فيما سماها ادعاءات الكسب غير المشروع
في رد مكتوب بدل المثولي امام لجنه
المحاسبه الوطنيه الى اللقاء